Buenos días yaku es una palabra quechua
que significa agua con este nombre los
científicos bautizaron al ciclón que
está ocasionando más de 2.300 viviendas
afectadas la muerte de siete personas
escuelas y centros de salud colapsados
desbordes de ríos calles inundadas en el
norte del Perú justamente el centro
operativo de emergencia nacional ha
señalado que Trece regiones del país se
encuentran en alerta roja debido a las
fuertes precipitaciones de estas lluvias
y precisamente señalan que en Lima va a
sufrir lluvias inusuales con
precipitaciones hasta cinco litros de
agua por metro cuadrado y eso señala los
científicos que va a activar más de 30
quebradas en la capital peruana donde
habitan personas de condición humilde
que se van a encontrar vulnerables ante
esta situación de emergencia que se
podría presentar
y ya mencionábamos que una de las
acciones es que el gobierno declaró
estado de emergencia Pero qué más están
haciendo las autoridades
Sí justamente el estado de emergencia
comprende a Lima y otras seis regiones
vulnerables del Norte del país
precisamente la ministra de vivienda ha
adelantado que esta medida va a
contemplar en la entrega de bonos
mensuales a las familias damnificadas la
presidenta Dina boluarte y sus
principales ministros ya se encuentran
en tumbes en la región norte del país
para evaluar las condiciones de
emergencia que están viviendo los
pobladores de esa localidad y planificar
la entrega de ayuda humanitaria la
agenda de la mandataria peruana incluye
el desplazamiento hacia otras cuatro
regiones para poner este en afectividad
al ejército peruano llevar maquinaria
para reforzar las Riberas de los ríos
rescatar personas que se encuentren en
situación de urgencia y también activar
la entrega de ayuda humanitaria con
alimentos y medicinas